المعارك في بلده سوليدار الاوكرانيه
متوسطه بين الجيش الاوكراني والجيش الروسي
الذي يحاول تحقيق اول اختراق في ميدان
المعركه منذ سته اشهر وفيما تنفي اوكرانيا
ان تكون المدينه قد سقطت في ايدي مجموعه
مرتزقه فاجنر دعا الكريملين الى عدم
التسرع في اعلان الانتصار في المدينه
باستخدام مرتزقه فاتنر 9 روسيا لاحكام
السيطره على مدينه سوليدار تمهيدا لتطبيق
مدينه باخموطه الاستراتيجيه ومن ثم فتح
الطريق امام الجيش الروسي للوصول الى
المدن الكبرى في منطقه ايدون يسكن
وهنا يواجه الجيش
والتي باتت اكثر النقاط سخونه على جبهه
المعارك في اوكرانيا
لمواصله لمساعده الاوكرانيين انهم قتيلون
من اجل حريتنا ايضا
الصمود في وجه الاله العسكريه الروسيه
التي تحاول دفع القوات الاوكرانيه
للانسحاب الى جيوب البلده من الجهه
الغربيه لا يزال متواصلا رغم قصف الطريق
السريع الذي يرسل الامدادات العسكريه
للمنطقه وضرب كل نقاط الاتصال بين القياده
والجنود في ذات الوقت تتجه كتائب من
القوات الخاصه الروسيه للناحيه الشماليه
نحو مدينه سيفرز التي تتمركز فيها قوات
الاوكرانيه والواقعه بين
سولدر من اجل السيطره على المحور الشمالي
باكمله من دنياك في المرحله المقبله